Before we dive into the nuts and bolts of how GMS is implemented, how it is
architected, let's first understand at the high level
what's going on in terms of page fault
handling now that we have this community service
underlying GMS. In this picture, I am showing
you two hosts, host P and host Q and you can see that the physical memory
on this host is divided into the local and
the global part. Similarly, the physical memory on host Q
is divided into the local part and the global
part. And we already mentioned that these are not fixed
in size but the size actually fluctuates depending on
the activity and that's what we are going to illustrate through
a example situations. So the most common case is
that I am running a process on P and that
page faults on some page X. When that happens, you have to find out if this
page X is in the global cache of some node in the cluster. let's say that this
page happens to be in the global cache of node Q. So what will happen in
order to handle this page fault is the
GMS system will locate, oh this particular page it's
on host Q. So it'll go to host Q. And the host Q will then
send the page X over to node P and clearly, if there there was a page fault that
means that the memory pressure on host P
is increasing and therefore, it is going to add X
to it's current working set. That is it's
local allocation of the physical memory is going to go
up by one but it cannot go up by one
without getting rid of something here. Because the sum of
the local and global is the total amount of physical
memory available in this node and therefore, what P is going
to do is, pick the oldest page that's available in
the global part and send it over to node Q. So,
in other words, what we are doing so far, as
host Q is concerned is saying, well X happens to be
currently in the working set, then resend it to host
P. And host P says, well, my working set is
increasing. Therefore, I have to shrink my community service and
we going to reduce the global part by one. Pick the
oldest page. let's say it's Y. Send it over to
host Q. So that the host Q can host this
new page Y in the global cache on this node.
The key take away for you is that, for this
particular common case, the memory pressure pressure
on p is increasing, so the local
allocation of the physical memory goes up
by one, and the global allocation, the community
service part goes down by one on host P. Where as on host Q, it
remains unchanged because all that we have done is we have traded Y for X.